-It is the holiday season,
and the Rockefeller Center
Christmas tree is here.
If you guys haven't seen it yet,
here it is.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-I don't want to say
anything too mean.
It looks like it could use
some encouragement
before its big lighting
later this month,
so I wrote a tiny song.
I hope you like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ You're 82 feet
and essentially flawless ♪
♪ But we can't help but notice
you have male pattern baldness ♪
♪ Just a week ago, we couldn't
wait for you to show up ♪
♪ But now we're
all wondering when
you'll g-g-g-g-glow up ♪
♪ Time for a glow-up,
a Midtown makeover ♪
♪ Let's get the "Queer Eye" guys
to do a t-t-t-t-takeover ♪
♪ It's time for a glow-up,
you're looking pretty poor-ah ♪
♪ So let's go get free samples
at S-S-S-S-Sephora ♪
♪ It's time for a glow-up,
you might need to go faster ♪
♪ We don't want to wait,
this isn't T-T-Ticketmaster ♪
♪ It's time for a glow-up,
I know you're not a quitter ♪
♪ At least you're doing better
than they are at T-T-T-Twitter ♪
♪ It's time for glow-up ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you very much.